[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pierre pierre pierre pierre pierre
pierre
c'est moi qui poserai la première
question si vous permettez répondez-moi
honnêtement est-ce que vous avez répété
non mais
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire Pierre
Perret vous êtes fait connaître au début
des années 60 avec des chansons
gauloises parfois même grivoises puis
vos ritournelles sont devenues de plus
en plus militants vous avez commencé à
écrire vous êtes mis à faire des
dictionnaires des anthologies vous êtes
entrés au Conseil supérieur de la langue
française et aujourd'hui vous êtes un
monument national qu'est-ce que je
voulais que je vous dise écoutez il y a
même des écoles et des rues qui portent
votre nom c'est incroyable non jamais
j'ai pensé une seconde au quart du
millième de ce qui m'est arrivé parce
que j'ai toujours été un
enfant un rêveur assez timide et
contemplatif finalement j'étais heureux
de tout la première fois que papa m'a
demandé quand j'avais mon petit
certificat d'études en poche maintenant
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire j'ai dit
mais moi papa rien
est-ce que vous avez pensé à enfant
qu'un jour vous seriez à Tout le monde
en parle et que vous auriez un triomphe
romain
[Musique]
et voilà
alors
heureusement heureusement vous êtes
toujours restés extérieur à votre
personnage public et vous avez toujours
cette simplicité malgré vos succès
oui mais je trouve pas grand mérite à ça
parce que d'abord je pense que ça serait
trop fatiguant d'être différent jouer la
star ça vous fatiguerez oui vous jouez
un personnage à longueur de journée je
ne sais pas ce qui arrive à le faire
sont des gens beaucoup plus forts que
moi
alors vous êtes ici Pierre Perret pour
une double attitude d'abord un CD
ensuite un livre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir c'est les trompettes de la
renommée
c'est
nunuche à dire mais mais ça rembourse de
plein de moments de solitude quand on
est juste avec un stylo voilà
alors Pierre Perret dans votre dernier
CD comme depuis quelques années vous
abordez des problèmes de société assez
grave mais toujours avec votre langage
coloré
et vous dénoncez dans ce disque les
déviances sexuelles les sectes le dopage
dans le sport la guerre la pollution la
drogue le racisme les marchands d'armes
les dangers du du tabac vous croyez pas
que finalement c'est un petit peu
enfoncé les portes ouvertes non
si sans doute je ne suis pas le seul à
parler de ça on tourne un bouton on
écoute ça toute la journée bon je pense
que c'est par un prisme un peu
particulier qui est le mien qui est un
œil une vision de la chose je pense
qu'il est jamais superflu de rappeler
aux enfants que un dealer c'est de la
merde et dealers que c'est de la merde
d'un dealer c'est jamais inutile de le
dire même aux enfants et j'espère qu'un
jour ces chansons-là seront apprises
dans les maternelles même celles qui
portent mon nom alors est-ce que c'est
pas difficile finalement de dénoncer les
malheurs du monde la misère du monde
quand on vit dans une maison de rêve
comme ça Nangis en Seine-et-Marne avec
20000 bouteilles de vin dans sa cave
est-ce que il y avait un décalage c'est
la seule chose qui est mon bien ma
richesse mon bonheur celui d'avoir une
maison accueillante pour y accueillir
sur tous les amis et puis bon j'ai pas
de laverie automatique j'ai pas de de de
restaurant sur les Champs-Élysées
à faire de la bouffe rapide de ça
m'intéresse pas ce d'argent là
m'intéresse pas il y a deux trois ans on
a vu revenir Georges Brassens d'un seul
coup les Français se sont rendus compte
que Brassens je parle des jeunes
évidemment sont rendus compte que
Brassens c'était un chanteur de folk
français quoi et que c'était intéressant
et j'ai l'impression que vous êtes le
suivant je voyais l'autre jour un
journal comme libération qui vous rend
hommage sur une demi-page
ça aurait pas été le cas il y a 5 ou 10
ans hein
peut-être oui je ne sais pas ce qui leur
arrive à tous
alors
on va maintenant passer à la deuxième
actu de Pierre Perret donc ça c'est un
dictionnaire qui s'appelle le parler des
métiers et c'est édité chez Robert
Laffont
alors on s'empêche 13210 sont très 145
professions alors c'est ni sur l'argonie
sur les vieux métiers c'est sur les
métiers d'aujourd'hui c'est très actuel
bien sûr c'est tous les métiers
d'aujourd'hui vers lesquels j'ai envoyé
des enquêteurs principalement des
linguistes qui savaient de quoi il
parlait qui savait poser les bonnes
questions parce que c'est pas toujours
évident et il y avait principalement des
femmes qui sont allées un peu dans tous
les coins de l'hexagone pour questionner
des gens qui mettaient les sardines en
bois qui faisaient de la viticulture qui
était cordonnées qui étaient flics qui
étaient
pour rapprocher 250 métiers il en faut
beaucoup alors ils se retrouvaient même
dans les commissariats ou des églises ou
des morgues avec en questionnant des
gens pour obtenir parfois des locutions
assez assez cocasse
hallucinant ou curieuse c'est vous qui
les avez payé
oui
l'Académie française d'envoyer des gens
dans les provinces pour recueillir les
les jargon c'est un travail qui aurait
été certainement dans leur domaine et
c'était plutôt à eux de recueillir ce
patrimoine comme moi parce que je ne
suis qu'une personne toute seule
physique bon mais ça m'a fait un plaisir
fou de m'offrir ça parce que je me suis
offert ça alors en 63 moi j'avais 14 ans
quand votre premier succès le tord-boyau
est sorti et j'ai appris en préparant
cette interview qu'en fait c'était pas
complètement innocent parce que vous
êtes né dans un café restaurant vos
parents étaient bistrotiers et quand on
sait ça c'est explique assez bien votre
votre truculence votre humour votre
façon d'être vos parents s'appelaient
Maurice et Claudia Perret et ils avaient
le café du pont à Castelsarrasin à la
sortie de la ville entre l'usine
d'aluminium et la caserne
et alors ça a été votre école de la vie
c'est le Bistrot de vos parents oui
parce que autour d'un comptoir dans un
café et les clients refont vraiment le
monde et puis votre mère qui voulait
vous envoyer vous coucher qui vous tirez
par la Manche le soir les propos de
donner un peu ce que c'est sûr entendu
entre te coucher la phrase c'était
Pierrot à la cuisine
il pleut à 14 ans en conservatoire de
Toulouse 15 ans Conservatoire d'art
dramatique 19 ans premier prix de saxo
et accessible de comédie et puis début
sur les planches vous commencez à
vouloir jouer et là il y a un libraire
qui vous fait découvrir la lecture qui
qui vous passe des des classiques
français quoi c'est lui qui vous a
vraiment branché sur les mots oui un
monsieur merveilleux qui a comblé les
lacunes qui étaient les miennes parce
que partir après un certificat d'études
et je trouvais confronté au texte de
Molière Shakespeare ou Courteline ou
Musset j'étais très malheureux et même
un peu humilié il faut bien le dire
parce que c'est très très plaisir quand
on sait pas on entre dans un monde on
comprend pas tout personnellement c'est
moi qui ai une sensibilité quand même
et un jour ce monsieur je suis rentré
pour acheter un
bouquin au rabais je crois que je jouais
les plaiders le petit Jean des plaideurs
la racine
j'ai demandé un bouquin bon marché et
cela attendrait il m'a vu il m'a dit bon
ben venez et il m'a amené dans une
caverne d'Ali Baba qu'il avait hors de
la librairie à 100 mètres de là et
c'était des anciennes caves de de qui
datait des
de de 3 ou 400 ans
et il y avait des trésors là-dedans
du bouquin de théâtre de poésie de tout
mais du bouquins très anciens
il m'a laissé me servir et il m'a mis en
main des ouvrages que j'aurais jamais
lu tout seul vous montez à Paris vous
êtes fan de Brassens à l'époque et vous
allez voir dans dans sa loge vous
vouliez d'amitié avec avec Brassens et
c'est ça sa compagne pub chaîne qui vous
a
dit de chanter d'une certaine façon vous
y pas le faire avant j'ai dit mais je
suis pas chanteur mais Georges non plus
alors vous êtes remarqué féliciter à
l'époque donc par Boris Vian et Jacques
Canetti grand grand homme s'il en fut
Canetti découvreur de talent hors pair
Eddy Barclay vous signes et là vous
faites la connaissance de Simone
mazaltarin qui devient votre compagne
après que vous l'ayez rebaptisé Rebecca
quand même hein oui c'est vrai sinon
on épouse toujours la même c'est fou 40
ans d'acharnement thérapeutique
[Rires]
mais Simone c'est plus qu'une épouse
c'est votre muse votre secrétaire votre
votre attaché de presse je ne fais rien
de d'importance je veux dire sans en
référé avec elle et l'oeil et l'oreille
les plus importants pour moi
pour eux sur pour une chanson nouvelle
c'est son œil et son oreille si jamais
elle a une réaction mitigée sur une
chanson je peux être malade pendant une
semaine sans le dire à personne mais je
vais avoir les patates au fond du filet
pendant une semaine la c'est sûr alors
comme vous êtes un fou des mots on va
vous faire une interview par les jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va voir peut-être ça sera votre
prochain dictionnaire est-ce que vous
savez ce que veut dire qui fait ça
c'est c'est
l'équivalent de symbole non voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est du style
[Musique]
oui d'accord c'est un peu dégueulasse
votre truc
que c'est peerave
c'est un peu périmé quoi non oui
si je dis Pierre Perret je suis grave
vénère ça veut dire quoi
très énervé très bien
un gag c'est quoi un gag
alors là je vous signale c'est dans mon
dictionnaire alors
le Toshi
[Applaudissements]
une tasse P c'est quoi une tapée
ben c'est tout sauf ma femme d'accord
[Applaudissements]
oui mais bon c'est pas mon truc
c'est de la balle c'est ce que ça veut
dire quand on dit c'est de la balle
c'est de la daube non
pierre
ça fait partie du javanais matinée de
verlan on peut se faire pépon
je comprends je
comprends
et si je vous dis pierre tu déchires
ah ça me fait vachement plaisir et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu